[Music]
[Applause]
he's greg sankey the sec commissioner
who joins us on the program good to have
you back commissioner
i'm wondering when you go to a party
how often or how long does it take
before somebody brings up
football in the sec and what other
schools you're going to add
about 30 seconds
right now
you know it varies so last summer it
flared and then we play the season and
then
other topics take over in season and
then the last what six seven weeks it's
been the first question in most
encounters
kind of hard to hide what you do for a
living isn't it
it is in fact i was at a little
breakfast place two weeks ago in a place
called skinny atlas new york where i
grew up and i finished a conversation
with someone and the guy next to me
walks up and says hey i love when you're
on the dan patrick show and i'm not
making this up just to just to play up
to the host and i was trying to figure
out the last time i had been on
and uh
it was probably pandemic yes yeah it
seems like but but it happens and and
then the the question was hey what do
you think's going to happen with all
this conference movement
how would you sum up the last year
oh wow you know i i went to our staff
last year at this time and i said what
if last year was easier meaning 2021
when we were in the middle of pandemic
just to think about
the issues we face
it has been relentless
no complaints in that because part of
the job of leadership is to deal with
those challenges head-on
and then i actually went away for the
fourth of july weekend thinking naively
i'd have five days just to read books
and not think about
football or baseball you know ole miss
has just won the college world series
and then literally the first morning of
what i thought would be my long weekend
was uh the usc ucla news and it just
ramps up not that we were
trying to do something you know we had
made what i think is a great move last
year with the additions of oklahoma and
texas but just dealing with all the
incoming inquiries both inside my league
and from the outside of my league
what do you consider the biggest threat
to the ability stability of college
athletics today
sometimes it's hard to reduce that just
to one one
meaningful issue i think one of the big
threats is the ability to have a common
national standard for competition
national championships the final four
the college world series the college
football playoff
have been based on some commonality of
competition
and as we're in this new era of
decisions by states to legislate
how we administer college athletics
uh the legal challenges to the ncaa's
authority
i would suggest that the stability
issues are affected greatly by the
ability to have a national platform then
every time you have this this conference
movement at the high end it certainly
magnifies
the concern about stability and
consistency and really sustainability
can you still have a home office for the
ncaa can the ncaa continue to be the
ncaa
i think so one of the the mantras that i
shared with our coaches is things are
never going to be the way they were and
we have to understand that reality but
it doesn't have to be the way that it is
and rather than complaints and
criticisms and simple solutions to
complex problems we need some deep
engaged thinking which is challenging
given the amount that's happening around
us
uh and the disparate issues are just
trying to run leagues on a day-to-day
basis that said
i'm one who thinks there's a place for a
national association
but but my concern is the ability for
the ncaa particularly in division one
to adapt in a timely manner in a way
that sustains that national platform for
for national competition
would you like to run the ncaa
that's really not on my my list of
priorities today i i
i've enjoyed
uh would you like to run college
football
same because there's not
i'm going to back up and say that's the
old czar notion so czars haven't really
worked well in like russian history or
the drug czar and that's about you know
granting authority to just make
decisions so that's like an extreme
hypothetical
i think we need some deep thought with
some really focused leaders away from
committee structures
i tend to think you grab really bright
people put them in a room and give them
four or five days to figure out
solutions you can have the kind of
outputs that sustain things moving
forward rather than we've got to have
everybody represented
represented on a committee from every
different level so that we satisfy every
interest and
you know i'm co-chairing a
transformation committee which is a lot
of work and the challenge is we're
talking of transformation while we're
still stuck
in the historical mindset of college
sports
talking to greg sankey the sec
commissioner i know you're a big runner
it feels like we're at mile
five or six of uh
of a five-year marathon so give me what
is your five-year plan for the sec
well back up so i've finished 41
marathons in my lifetime and the great
lesson of marathoning is
uh the the misnomer is 13.1 miles is
halfway you know 20 miles into a
marathon you're halfway because those
last six miles
are the hard part
um if i were to look out first of all i
don't think you can just say here's our
five-year plan so we don't engage in
strategic planning per se we engage here
in the southeastern conference in
strategic thinking which is every time
we gather together you analyze what's
happening you analyze the issues you
have the right kind of counsel generally
from the outside certainly around
legislative and legal issues and then
you think forward
so as i think forward uh the ncaa has to
adapt is an association we're not in
this well maybe we should maybe we
should and we're seeing some of that
right now i'll go back though dan to
what i observe that we we have a lot of
past thinking that still is attached to
how we're making decisions moving
forward in a modern era
i think conferences are important so if
you're asking me three to five years out
i think conferences are still important
i think there's meaning for a context of
competition um college athletics is very
different than professional sports
people can opine about whether or not
that's true
i think we need national standards
around certain issues i think certainly
academic eligibility how we conduct
ourselves with education at the center i
think health and safety standards are
important and then i think when we get
into to recruiting structures how we
play the season those are important
parts we're continuing to think about
how we support student athletes and
there are any number of opinions about
that but that model will continue to
adapt as we've seen over the last five
years the question is going to be can we
do that
in collaboration with people including
our congressional legislators or are we
going to do that through the the court
systems as we've done over the last
decade or so when's the last time you
had a university reach out to you to
join the sec
uh nobody calls and says can i join it
usually begins with a conversation hey
how you doing i wanted to talk to you
some key issues and then at the end
hey if anything ever changes let me know
and what i tried to communicate at our
media days is we're really confident in
who we are
we're we're committed and convinced we
made two really wise additions and i
think that shows itself to be true right
now in the university of oklahoma but
when was your last time you had that
conversation commissioner last week last
week you had a president
hey how you doing no you know it's a
different different folks hey how are
you doing if you ever think about it you
know keep us in mind which is a
compliment that's we're not out on the
recruiting trail we're not looking to go
beyond 16 there's not some magic number
um and that's where i say dan we're
confident and comfortable in the
decisions we've made so far but is there
a move that could happen that would
change
your strategy
well we're really aware of what's
happening around us and it's tough to
answer every hypothetical we've
we've shown to be adaptable in unique
circumstances so we're going to continue
to to be adaptable as needed with the
priority on who we are and i'll go back
to what i communicated again at our
media days which is
i don't think about numbers um people
don't really think through the economics
of expansion so you don't want to just
diminish
your financial support to your current
members to just add to achieve a number
so
philosophical approach to high level
nationally competitive athletics or
cultural fit um are really important and
that's what we've done in our most
recent expansions with texas a m
missouri and now oklahoma and texas
have you heard from notre dame
not i don't talk about uh membership
conversations but i talked to jack
because we chaired up we we shared a
role on the college football playoff
committee and we're all trying to figure
out how to move forward with the college
football playoffs so
you should understand conversations i
have go well beyond anything related to
membership and those are the appropriate
kind of professional conversations we
should always have
if you look at the model that could
happen in five years let's say you have
16
team playoff
let's say
maybe you have a four team playoff in
the sec
to get to
you know number of teams that will
qualify for the playoff system
let's say you have a kind of an afc and
an nfc and you have
maybe 60 teams involved
may do do you like where i'm going with
any of this stuff there commissioner
i'm following the trail of who does what
um
we we talked in and i'll go back to the
work in the college football playoff
that focused on a 12 team approach
and i think that was really well
informed and provided some opportunities
for conference champions for a lot of
at-large births and still
a bold system that could go forward for
those teams trying to emerge
competitively when you expand that
number you diminish the likelihood that
there's anything more than a playoff um
i didn't follow all the numbers
one of the the news points
uh somebody probably have to help me
back in the spring
early summer was the sec is going to run
its own playoff and as we looked at our
new approach to scheduling we had
conversations about what if but the
notion that we just have a playoff right
now is not at the forefront of our
thinking
what do you think of what i said about
60 teams
and 60 60.
so let's say i focused on 16 that's my
bad audio
yes 660 for the entire sport that
you know you have 30 over here 30 over
here i mean you almost treat it like
it's the nfl from the standpoint of
you know you
section teams over here and then they
eventually meet for a super bowl like uh
could there be relegation in college
football
of you know having 60 teams and then
somebody drops out and somebody gets uh
promoted
yeah so that would be
that hypothetical would be based on a
very different model and structure where
people would have to take
different approach to their alignments
their scheduling philosophies and i know
i i thought you had said 16 earlier yeah
let's just pick 60. so i'll play the
game okay you know the first question
would be when are we going to 64 or 68
right so that that's the reality where
trying to to jump in and speculate on
numbers becomes
um a bit of an inefficient way to
evaluate opportunity but let's say i
took the sec in the big ten and then i
brought in
some other stragglers from the big 12 or
pac-12 and then you just made it two
different conferences there not
everybody makes the playoffs i'm just
saying that that's you guys just play
each other like the the nfc and the afc
and then you have a 16 team playoff
yeah great question but i'm probably not
jumping into that one
probably smart doing that
that's right
that's why that's why we have to come
back and talk more often
um
so your your
role with jimbo fisher and nick saban
when that happened so when you hear it
or you see it
your first phone call is to who
um and actually they come to me rather
quickly so i first i i was in new york
city
were they summoned commissioner did you
summon saban and uh
no no no there's a there's a picture
that circulated on social medias after
that it happened i was like 11 o'clock
in new york one of my staff said hey you
need to know about this interview and by
the time i didn't really sleep well that
night because it's a bit of a kidney
punch no i'm gonna have to deal with it
and then it starts with phone calls the
next morning you speak with both
athletics directors
uh i talked and listened to both coaches
and said here's what we're gonna have to
do and kind of escalated through the day
and and then dan when we went to our
spring meetings which are held in destin
florida
uh we we peaked our media attendance and
everybody's looking for something to
happen somebody tweeted out a seating
chart from our football coaches meeting
which i never thought i'd have to worry
about that particular
piece of confidentiality jimbo was our
chair
and we had a great deep conversation
about what's happening around us in
college football and that's where i
began with look you have to understand
things are not going to be the way they
work whatever we've known for 20 30
years past
that's not the way it's going to be but
it doesn't have to be the way that it is
and what i need is the really bright
people around the sport to engage in
problem solving with me and that's where
accusations and complaints don't solve
problems
and everybody thinks all you do is deal
with football you're the sec
commissioner you have to deal with all
the ancillary stuff as well
i i've said to a couple pro league
commissioners and and coaches and team
presidents like if i could have one
sport to worry about that'd be played
that'd be great but we have 21
championships we're proud of what we do
and we've got women's soccer competition
the pre-season competition that starts
on our campuses this week and
we've got some contenders for the
women's volleyball national championship
so we'll get after it do the best we can
to support high level college sports in
a great way all right don't be a
stranger you know
it's
it felt like you started running your
forrest gump you just kept running away
from the show there and you know we want
to make sure that you don't run too far
it's always important to have something
interesting to talk about so you've got
my number let me know when you want me
back and that guy in skinny alice new
york tell me how great i was again in
about three months i appreciate that
thank you thank you commissioner we
appreciate your time
thanks dan take care that's greg sankey
scc commissioner